the other guy I did I think is the first
person I discovered that you
investigated as Brian Rose of London
real
can you talk about his story
um
Brian Rose he was sort of this
interesting figure because he was like
trying to be to one level or another The
Joe Rogan of London which I don't think
he did a terribly bad job of especially
initially he had some really interesting
podcasts with some really interesting
people and uh it's funny enough I
started out as a like I would watch him
I mean I don't know if I was like a huge
fan but I was like I like some of his
interviews he had some really good like
big gits in terms of you know great
guests
um however when kind of covid started he
went down this really weird
grifting Rabbit Hole where he did like
this interview with David Ike who's as
you know like a pretty big coveted
conspiracy theorist
um and I mean like actual like he
believes some of the Royals are
literally lizards
um so he got shut down for that
and uh he kind of made a big stink which
it's I think it's fine nobody likes to
be censored and I'm not even saying that
he should have been censored but his
reaction to that was to like raise a ton
of money from his audience promising
this digital Freedom platform and at
first it was like oh we want to raise a
hundred thousand dollars and then they
raised it like within a day so he's like
well we gotta raise a lot more money and
So eventually they raised a million
dollars and he's trying to raise 250 000
a month to kind of keep putting
his viewers money into this stuff so I
started digging into the platform they
were building and there was nothing free
about it they had censorship guidelines
and there was nothing about a platform
at all there was no underlying
infrastructure he just got some White
Label uh live streaming thing so I
criticized him for that it was just this
ridiculous thing all the donators
expected one thing they they thought
Brian Rose was going to take on Google
and Facebook and like bring Free Speech
back for everybody and of course he
didn't
um and then it kind of got worse because
he started taking a lot of heat for that
and he really pivoted hard until like
the defy grift so he started selling
this course about defy Mastery and this
is a guy who knows nothing about crypto
um or very little at the least so it
just got really kind of he just kind of
um doubled down on this course model of
you're going to be rich if you just
follow me and it was
ultimately you just type in Brian rose
on on YouTube you can see what his
audience thought of that because almost
all of them have left him at this point
he's getting like a thousand views of
video
and it wasn't because of me I mean it
was like people lost taste in just the
constant ask for more money more money
more money at some point people get sick
of it and it's like everyone has an
understanding that like no one works for
free but when it starts to be ego driven
and driven around money everything's
about money it uh it drives people away
well you're a part of that sort of
helping people it's nice to have a voice
yeah I certainly spoke out I mean it
wasn't like I was quiet I was very loud
about it at the time
um but I mean in the sense that
there
if you look at someone like Andrew Tate
I made a video about him even though
he's been banned off all the platforms
he gets more views than Brian Rose
and
I think it's just like it was a
testament to how much Brian Rose was
like doing like the grift that people
could even people who were fans and
didn't care about what I said like
couldn't look past you know just the
constant ask for more and more money
people just get burned out